what does it mean to be here tonight and
just to celebrate the culture it means
everything i'm celebrating the culture
we're celebrating black women
we're also celebrating my birthday so it
is a very
big day that's what i wanted to ask you
what are you doing for your birthday
we saw like when when album dropped you
are running around the house and all
excited what are you gonna do for your
birthday what am i doing for my birthday
i'm gonna kill the stage is what i'm
gonna do for my birthday
i know you're the killer stage but i
know you're doing something for your
birthday oh man i actually had a little
celebration last night but we all gonna
go back to the house and eat yeah that's
what we're doing all right performing
tonight what does it mean to be out on
that stage and like look out and you're
like
i missed y'all oh my gosh you have no
idea i'm so excited to see all the faces
and
it's just it just feels warm that's what
it feels like but you're going to see
something from me that you have not seen
before so
it's going to be extra super special
really oh yeah people don't really get
to
see me play the drums as much so you
know i'm premiering my song we made it
off my new album back in my mind
and yeah the energy is is crazy crazy
the energy it took to deliver this album
and finally get it out there make it
ready and everybody was waiting what was
that
it was a little bit of pressure i think
so but i had to let it go and just
create
honestly i just wanted to make good
music music that resonates with me
because at the end of the day if it's
authentic to me then i know people will
connect to it you know that's kind of
what i thought about going into that
process
who are the black women that inspired
you oh my gosh there's so many alicia
keys is definitely number one
i know we're honoring queen latifah and
she has been a huge uh
person just in the culture for the
culture that has inspired i think
everybody
but um missy elliott um aaliyah
janet jackson lauren hills a big one so
many i love what you're wearing tonight
what is it like becoming this style icon
because it's
there's two things that i think are
important yes yes yes oh
thank you so much honestly um the thing
i love about
fashion and working with my stylist is
we we dress from the inside out
and and you know it's all about how you
feel and and uh yeah
i think that's what translates so it
translates it really does
thank you so much and good luck tonight
it's great seeing you again yeah
you